do you still contact her do you still no
but i think she's still
just she's i always talk about her you
thanked her ever did you ever yeah
no of course yeah
you know um she put me in
i think she was the one who was costing
spartacus
wow she's the one who casts spartacus
yeah he has a funny story about that
so this is talk about totally naive that
was an intense show intense
and also we were like one of the we were
like the first
like really rudy nudie shows it was
beauty like really rude two episodes and
it was nudie and rudy yeah very nerdy
and rooty so um
but like so wonderful like heightened
language and like the costumes and the
world i remember walking on there just
being like oh my god what was the
language like well it's you know it's
steven tonight was the showrunner and he
was so wonderful i worked with him yeah
he directed an episode of small he's a
great guy yeah he's wonderful wonderful
and um
he you know it's
like your hat my hands serviced dominant
alone
she would not be pleased to have yours
laid upon me without her consent like
that sort of stuff yeah
um it's like [ __ ] off in like a very
polite way completely don't touch me
and
i
auditioned for that show
i i'll preface this by saying i was an
i.t recruitment consultant before all of
this and then i worked in sales and
marketing and i was a red bull girl i
had like a whole life before acting wow
and then uh
i go and i auditioned for two shows one
local and then spartacus was for stars
and american and i call my agent
and i walk out of this article's edition
and i was like i got it and she was like
oh well i'm glad it went well but you
actually have an offer for this like
other show so wonderful like you can
take it i was like no no no i'm going to
do the american one
and she was like no leslie and this is
not how it works i was like alice
i've booked the role i'm fine you can
tell them no thank you well they haven't
called me
exactly what you said and alice was like
all right darling we'll just table it
for now
and we'll you know 45 minutes she called
me back she goes well you got the roll
on spot i guess
wow i don't know it's a blind confidence
you know